today you were going to be learning
about dynamic equilibrium this is quite
a strange feature so it needs some
explaining if we break it down into two
words we have equilibrium which would
mean everything's equal and yet dynamic
would suggest movement so it would
suggest that although everything's equal
things are moving and the best way to
consider that is to imagine running on a
treadmill so you've seen people at gyms
running along for miles and miles and
miles and yet they never appear to move
anywhere because on their machine as
they're running as they're running along
the treadmill is moving in one direction
as they're running in the other so the
equal part is their position because
their position stays the same and yet
they have because of the treadmill moved
and that's a great example of dynamic
equilibrium things appear to be equal
and yet there's lots of movement
occurring now in science this most often
occurs when we see something called a
reversible reaction the most common one
of which is called the harbor process
and it is the method of production of
ammonia but in an example of a
reversible reaction we have our
reactants perhaps a plus B in a reaction
followed by this symbol and then this
might join together to make the compound
a B the symbol here is suggesting that
there is movement in one direction for
words but there is also movement in the
opposite direction backwards i reverse
and that's what makes this a reversible
reaction now so explain further
this means that
a and B are reacting and they're
reacting to form a B but as they react
to form a B a B is just chemically
breaking down to form a plus B again so
in other words we have a plus B making a
B but at the same time a B is reacting
to make a plus B this means that we have
a reversible reaction it's going round
in a cycle so that gives us reversible
that's fine but that's our dynamism we
have things constantly breaking down and
being remade so what makes a dynamic
equilibrium well a fact is that as this
reaction is happening at some point
you're going to end up with a relatively
constant amount of a B because it's
always being made and a constant amount
of a plus B because it's always breaking
down and at that point it may be
something like if I put this down here a
plus B and a B that in a mixture there
might be 50 percent of the chemical is
in the form of a B and 50 percent is in
the form of a B together so that seems
fine we've got this mixture how does
that still make it dynamic though
because we've got 50 percent here and 50
percent here well the fact is although
it looks like this value is constant the
actual individual molecules and atoms
that are making up this a B and this a
plus B are actually changing all the
time
so some of this in any one instance I
will see maybe atom a and atom B as
being separate and then we've got
separate atoms here that are joined up
as a B whereas if I come back in ten
minutes time it might be the atom and
atom B have now combined and over this
side of the equation whereas the a and B
that we had here have now broken down
and gone over to this side I sometimes
view this as being like students with
girlfriends and boyfriends in the year
11 so in my class I'm
may have maybe two or three students
that have boyfriends or girlfriends at
the start of the year and at the end of
the year I might still have two or three
students that are in relationships
however it's not the same students
so although the proportion of students
in a relationship has stayed the same
the actual students that are in that
relationship has changed so we have the
constant proportions which makes it the
equilibrium but it is changing the
individuals which makes it dynamic that
is the dynamic equilibrium
now our really common example that we
see which is the harbor process is the
process by which we get ammonia from air
to make ammonia for fertilizers and in
that case we have nitrogen as a gas plus
hydrogen as a gas and that makes ammonia
as a molecule our compound in the
molecule now the thing with this is that
as you're making the ammonia the ammonia
is also constantly breaking down now in
this case the dynamic equilibrium means
that maybe something like 95% of the
reactants are separate as the ammonia
the nation' and the hydrogen and only 5%
is present as the ammonia and what we do
is we collect that ammonia and we remove
it the proportions here though can be
changed we can change the conditions in
the reaction to try and courage the
forward reaction to be greater than the
reverse reaction and if we can do that
we can encourage this percentage to
increase to maybe 15% and this to
decrease to maybe 85% and therefore we
make this reaction much more profitable
for us as chemists so the proportions
here depend on the conditions that we
apply to the reaction so that is
reversible reactions in summary as our
dynamic equilibrium
in summary dynamic equilibrium is where
we appear to have equal proportions in
reversible reactions and yet the actual
reactants and products are constantly
changing and the most common example of
that we find in the harbour process
where we have nitrogen and hydrogen
being used up to make ammonia but that
ammonia is constantly breaking down to
form nation' and hydrogen again